have any of these priests that have been
accused or even found guilty of
pedophilia said that it was the devil
that possessed them at that time
no but I remember even a you know Pope
Benedict even commenting when he was in
office that there were many people that
were ordained priests that never should
have been ordained priest that somehow
they would somehow they were able to
to get in it's like a cancer that
destroys from within But ultimately we
can't lament anything we have to say
this is our reality now and then how do
we face it
and then facing our own
you know flaws how do we come out even
stronger as a result of that the greater
danger would be just simply to run away
in the face of criticism I think we have
to face our criticism we have to stand
there and we have to take it whatever
ugliness or mother people want to sling
we have to take that
what can the church do to reverse this
negative outlook on the church that's
been in the spotlight for the last few
decades I think the church has to be
even more public in the old Latin phrase
mayakopa Mia culpa it's admit it's
admitting guilt not coming up with
excuses or whatever it's simply saying
I own this I own this ugliness
yeah but is that good enough
I think it's the first step
because we can never go back and we
can't undo anything that's been done
but we can own it
and then ultimately all we can do is
move forward and then hopefully the
experience of that ugliness
causes the church to have a different
Outlook or view on the world and its
mission
because that's even when it comes to
anything to do with the demonic
how do we take what the devil is doing
and to turn it around and make something
good come from it
because we can't live in the past we
can't change the past ultimately all we
can do is learn from it and then move
forward
it said that the authenticity of any
apology would be manifest in tomorrow's
Behavior so if you apologize today then
hopefully we see the church and the
Servants of the church and the priests
of the church
over time tomorrow we see the service
that we had all hoped it was all about
best thing I ever heard was the
following and we'll wrap up on this the
best thing I ever heard from a pastor
you know when I was like what about this
and what about that and what about this
person what about that church and look
at what they're doing and they said
listen
if if your relationship with God's going
to be horizontal you're going to fail if
it's vertical you'll be fine he won't
let you down but people will let you
down people are always gonna let others
down because we're people no one walks
on water we make mistakes now that's a
royal Mistake by the church it's a royal
it's a royal mistake but you know if
you're gonna lean on a church to
uh do a hundred percent of things right
you will fail my biggest challenge is
when you have that kind of influence
don't use it to
uh impose so much fear to the point
where your your
immobilizing people inject more hope
inject more faith inject more you know
you and I can do special things with our
lives and make a positive impact so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here